last week it was paper cuts and this
week it's elephants or something like
that because today on cloud storage by
its we're talking about large file
uploads and how you can move mountains
in mere moments sometimes you've got
very large files that just seem to crawl
during upload let's say you've got a
data set with files from a few hundred
megabytes up to two gigs and this data
set is really giving you trouble if you
take a peek under the hood you'd notice
a slight upper limit in terms of upload
speeds let's also assume you're using
the python api meaning our trusty GSU
till now warns you that the file size is
too large if you take a closer look at
that warning it's making a potentially
game-changing suggestion use parallel
composite uploads for the best
performance when dealing with one or
more large files during parallel
composite uploads GS util splits your
larger files into smaller pieces and
then uploads them in parallel and then
composes them back together in your GCS
bucket it even cleans up after itself
removing all temporary components just
like what we saw in our parallel uploads
for the smaller files composite uploads
dramatically improve the performance
with larger files on some tests there's
as much as a two time improvement in the
upload speeds which means you're well on
your way to moving that mountain there's
more to come about large file
performance but we're gonna save that
for another episode if you want to know
more about parallel composite uploads
for large files check out the links in
the description and as always don't
forget to subscribe give us a like and
tell us what you want to learn about
Google Cloud storage thank you for
joining us for this quick byte of cloud
storage see you next time
[Music]